immer Vollgas geben im Beruf und bei der
Kindererziehung wo kommt das hin wo
kommt das hin richtig und nebenher noch
den Haushalt schmeißen allein erziehende
sind ständig im Stress an Tagen wo man
denkt man kann nicht mehr dann darf man
sich einfach nicht
hinsetzen sie tragen große
Verantwortung Mama als Mama kann man
nicht ersetzen und müssen immer für
andere da sein die Folgen sind häufig
Überlastung und Geldnot seit ich allein
erzehnt bin kann man ja nach den
heutigen Standard sagen ich bin
[Musik]
arm 5 Uhr morgens in
una die Krankenschwester Jessica Böcking
hat heute Frühdienst sie ist eine von
knapp 2,8 Millionen Alleinerziehenden in
Deutschland ihr Sohn Henry ist heute
Nacht auf die Wohnzimmercouch umgezogen
weil seine Zwillingsschwester so unruhig
geschlafen hat Alltag im
Alleinerziehenden Haushalt
[Musik]
Böcking damit sie rechtzeitig zu ihrer
Frühschicht aus dem Haus kommt muss
Jessica Gas geben eng getetaktet sagen
wir es mal so ne also wenn ich aufstehe
geht's ja direkt los ist jetzt nicht
setz mich erst no eine halbe Stunde hin
werd wach trinke in Ruhe mein Kaffee
muss schon zügig laufen und tatsächlich
so wenn irgendwas
Unvorhergesehenes passiert wird manchmal
schon bisschen stressig dann 6 Uhr jetzt
müssen auch die Kinder raus Maus du
musst wach werden heute ist
Schule jessica ist schon seit 5 Jahren
allein erzieh damals warenwi D Jahre alt
ihr ältester Sohn war neun seitdem
stemmt Sie den Alltag mit drei Kindern
allein diese hier
Romi ja ohne Pullover wird's aber ein
bisschen kalt dann nehmen wir den also
es muss immer alles genau dem gleichen
Ablauf folgen dann dann geht es aber es
ist schwierig an alles zu denken weil
wenn ich erstmal weg bin und der Tag
angelaufen ist dann lässt sich es auch
nicht mehr rückgängig machen dann muss
man das so nehmen wie es kommt guten
Morgen drei bis vier Mal die Woche
bekommt sie Unterstützung durch eine
ehrenamtliche helfferin Eulen und
Lärchen heißt das Projekt das Jessicas
Arbeitgeber mitfinanziert damit Sie auch
im Schichtdienst arbeiten kann ist auch
noch nicht so weit letzte Anweisungen
bevor es zur Arbeit geht so pass auf der
Bennet kocht nachher Nudeln für sich
vi44r kommen die Zwillinge nach Hause du
hast hörst die klingeln okay du hast
auch gehört ne 4R alleine ja gut perfekt
so
dann kussi bis später ich komme bis
später ich komme um 4:30 ja wenn was ist
ruft ihr an und wenn Hausaufgaben wenn
Schulsachen noch zu machen sind versucht
anzufangen hab einen schönen Tag ja du
auch bis morgen danke C nicht nur
zeitlich ist es eng sondern auch
finanziell Jessicas Exmann zahlt im
Monat nur 250 € Unterhalt für alle drei
Kinder zusammen
den Rest muss sie allein schultern ihre
Gedanken kreisen oft ums Geld man hofft
immer dass nichts mit dem Auto ist was
irgendwie teuer ist oder der Kühlschrank
kaputt geht oder die
Spülmaschine Klassenfahrten reißen auch
immer ein
riesenlch also diese extra Ausgaben sind
wirklich schwierig und man muss wirklich
wirklich
gucken bis zum Krankenhaus in Dortmund
braucht Jessica eine halbe bis
Dreiviertelstunde je nach Verkehr
ihre Frühschicht beginnt um 7:30 Uhr ab
dann gilt ihre Fürsorge den
Patienten dann müssen Sie die Arme aus
dem Hemdchen rausmachen weil ich alle
meine Kabel hier anbringen muss 30
Stunden in der Woche arbeitet Jessica
laut Vertrag um finanziell über die
Runden zu kommen macht sie sehr viele
Überstunden 12 bis 16 Stunden Tage sind
keine Ausnahme bei der Arbeit immer im
Hinterkopf ihre Kinder ich bin immer
froh wenn es kurz nach 8R ist wenn ich
wenn keiner angerufen hat dann weiß ich
okay sind alle in der Schule das läuft
alles da dürfte erstmal nichts mehr
passieren dann bin ich halbwegs
entspannt und dann werde ich erst wieder
hampelig ab vi44 Uhr wenn ich weiß die
Kleinen kommen nach Hause bis ich dann
einmal gehört habe die sind angekommen
und alles gut und dann dann dann weiß
ich dann läuft das auch aber ich mehr
Zeit für die Kinder wäre schön
finanziell ist das aber nicht
drin Geld das ist die größte Sorge von
madelen fahenbach mit ihrem Sohn schaut
sie beim Einkauf immer nach
Sonderangeboten der 13-Jährige würde
schon mal gerne eine fußballzeitschrift
kaufen aber solche extra Ausgaben sind
für den vierpersenhaushalt einfach nicht
drin madelen arbeitet 30 Stunden in der
Woche als technische Zeichnerin und
verdient 1500 €
netto ich gucke nach Sonderangeboten und
mittlerweile mit den Kindern die
Angebote am Wochenende durch und
überlegen so ein bisschen was wir essen
wollen und danach kaufen wir auch
ein so manch ist schon so dass ich sage
ich möchte einfach mal einkaufen gehen
ohne drauf achten zu müssen wie viel
dann am
Ende rauskommt würde ich schon gerne
machen stattdessen hält sich die Familie
streng an ihren Einkaufszettel was da
nicht drauf steht wird nicht
gekauft die Bonbons für norik bleiben
heute die einzig
süigkeit oh ich habe was gesehen was ich
möchte was da waren
Marshmallows guck
da eine Packung
mitnehmen die Kosten
schonordlich die Marshmallows landen
heute nicht im
Einkaufswagen sparen und verzichten
Alltag für viele alleinerziehende Mütter
ihr Armutsrisiko ist viermal so hoch wie
das von Müttern in paar Familien laut
einer Studie sind 43% der allein
erziehenden Arm du
[Musik]
darst seit ich allein erzähnt bin kann
man ja nach den heutigen Standard sagen
ich bin arm so also wir sind
wirtschaftlich gesehen Arm ich möchte
auch nicht immer irgendwo anders
hingehen müssen und sagen könnt ihr mir
mal helfen meine Eltern würden das
machen das weiß ich genau
aber es ist dann auch so eine so eine
gewisse Schamgrenze die da ist
bitte das heute ist nur so ein kleiner
Einkauf aber gerade wenn ich Getränke
mit hole geht's immer in dreistelligen
Bereich und ja das ist schon das ist
schon eine Hausnummer das
sind halt so ich sag mal so ein paar
Grundlebensmittel wo ich wo man es halt
deutlich merkt meine Kinder essen gerne
Joghurt mit Müsli oder andersrum Müsli
mit Joghurt und da hat sich der Preis
einfach
verdreifacht Millionen allein erziehende
haben nicht nur Geld
sorgen sie kämpfen auch mit der
Herausforderung das fehlende Elternteil
zu ersetzen Vater und Mutter
gleichzeitig zu
sein in goolf Kerstens Expartnerin ist
psychisch erkrankt und vor d Jahren
ausgezogen seitdem trägt er die
Verantwortung für die Kinder allein am
Anfang war es schwer die Rolle zu
übernehmen oder beide Rollen zu
übernehmen ich habe mich der
Herausforderung gestellt und dann im
Rahmen der Möglichkeiten ja habe dann
einfach gemacht also ich habe manchmal
gar nicht drüber nachgedacht und habe
einfach funktioniert sage ich mal in dem
Sinne 16 Uhr Ingolf holt seine Tochter
Anna von der Schule
ab der Garten und landschaftsbauhelfer
arbeitet 30 Stunden in der Woche er
verdient
1277 nto im Monat um Geld zu sparen
hilft es dass die Familie im eigenen
Garten Gemüse anbauen kann heute ernten
Lisa Anna und Ingolf Bohnen und
Zucchini die hier ja kann alle abflücken
Anna kannst du mir
helfen Lisas und Annas Mutter ist wegen
ihrer Erkrankung in Frührente sie zahlt
165 € Unterhalt im Monat für die beiden
Mädchen das Haus in dem die drei wohnen
hat Ingolf geerbt PAP Miete fällt so
nicht an doch die gestiegenen
Nebenkosten merkt die Familie alles ist
finanziell auf Kante genäht Essen aus
dem eigenen Garten ist da eine große
Hilfe
gr weil halt die Lebensmittelpreise ganz
schön gestiegen sind die Nebenkosten
sind d weitaus höher man guckt halt dass
man so weiter über die Runden gehen kann
oder guckt halt ob man irgendwas weiß
ich nicht Versicherung kündigen muss
oder so aber jetzt irgendwie die
Alternative dass man jetzt ein zweiten
Job annimmt kommt für mich gar nicht in
Frage weil das ist ja so schon alles
Stress
genug die große Mehrheit der
Alleinerziehenden sind Frauen dass Väter
diese Rolle übernehmen ist immer noch
die
Ausnahme doch ihr Anteil steigt 15%
aller Alleinerziehenden in Deutschland
sind Männer vor 10 Jahren waren es noch
10% lisa war 12 als ihre Mutter die
Familie verließ der Schmerz hältis heute
an ich wünsche mir auch dass ich auf
jeden Fall eine Mutter hätte die um mich
kümmert
Halt und dass sie halt auch Mutter für
mich die immer für mich da
ist jetzt mit 15 steckt Lisa mitten in
der
Pubertät 6 Uhr morgens in Halle madelen
macht Frühstück für ihre drei Kinder
seit 11 Jahren lebt die Familie ohne den
Vater alle zwei Wochen verbringen die
Kinder das Wochenende bei ihm den Alltag
muss die 43jährige alleine
bestreiten damit jedes Kind ein eigenes
Zimmer hat schläft Madlen im
Wohnzimmer wichtiger als ihre eigenen
sind die Bedürfnisse der Kinder und die
sind alle
unterschiedlich der mittlere der wenn
der sein Sport gucken darf ist der dann
recht zufrieden meine große die macht
ihr ihr Ding alleine und der kleine na
ja der braucht mancher
so Motivation und an schlechten Tagen
muss ich immer n noch sagen so jetzt
zieh dein Schlafanzug aus jetzt zieh
deine Unterhose an jetzt zieht deine
Socken an so ja aber es ist
sehr
tagesformabhängig
ja für alles alleine verantwortlich sein
immer zurückstecken das bleibt nicht
ohne Folgen
eine Studie zeigt Alleinerziehende sind
doppelt so oft unzufrieden mit ihrem
Leben wie Eltern in einer
Partnerschaft ich denke einfach dass die
Schwierigkeit auch ist dass meine Kinder
ja da drunter leiden dass ich oft in so
einem hohen Stresslevel bin dass ich nie
zur Erholung komme die Kinder sich
automatisch dafür verantwortlich fühlen
was sie ja gar nicht sind also ich
versuche meinen Kindern immer wieder zu
sagen ihr seid nicht dran schuld aber
ich glaube unterschwellig haben die
immer dieses Gefühl dass sie dran schuld
sind Madel läuft 30 Minuten zu Fuß zur
Arbeit die einzige Zeit am Tag die Sie
für sich selbst
[Musik]
hat
uns die Musik hilft gegen dunkle
Gedanken
also ich habe seit über 13 Jahren die
Diagnose der
Depression ich habe Phasen also gerade
ohne Medikamente
da ist es für mich ein unglaublicher
Kraftaufwand überhaupt aus dem Bett
aufzustehen
und ich habe das ganz lange ganz oft
gemacht für meine Kinder dass ich
aufgestanden bin und ich habe mich vor
ein paar Jahren mal von Arbeit auch
rausnehmen lassen weil da war ich bin
ich noch gependelt mit dem Auto weil
dieses Gefühl da war eigentlich hast du
keinen Bock mehr du lässt jetzt einfach
das Lenkrad los so und an diesem Punkt
ist dann mein Verantwortungsbewusstsein
gegenüber der Kinder schon so groß dass
ich sagen ne jetzt kannst du nicht
machen rund 15% der alleinerziehenden
Mütter haben Depressionen bei Müttern in
Partnerschaften sind es nur
[Musik]
6%. Madlen hat sich in einer Klinik
behandeln
[Musik]
lassen mit Hilfe von Medikamenten und
regelmäßigen Therapiesitzungen hat sie
ihre Depression inzwischen im
Griff Jessica Böcking hat heute ihren
freien Tag arbeiten muss sie aber
trotzdem zu
Hause gestern ist sie um 22 Uhr nach
Hause gekommen die Kinder waren längst
im Bett der Alltag als andauernde
Belastungsprobe für die Kinder ist es
auch nicht immer schön dass wir so
furchtbar geregelt sind und
durchgetaktet es ist selten spontan
irgendwas möglich das stört die ne dass
sie nicht spontan verabreden können das
geht nicht das geht nur vorgeplant weil
ich muss wissen wann komme ich da nach
Hause wann habe ich frei es kann niemand
hier hinkommen wenn ich nicht da bin für
die Kinder auch nicht einfach aber ich
glaube das ist das Wichtigste man muss
diszipliniert sein und man darf nicht
aufhören und an Tagen wo man denkt man
kann nicht mehr dann darf man sich
einfach nicht hinsetzen man setzt sich
nicht hin sondern so sucht sich eine
neue Aufgabe und dann macht man weiter
und dann hat man den Tag auch
geschafft eine kurze Pause mit Kaffee
und einer Zigarette gönnt sich Jessica
dann doch Kräfte
sammeln in 10 Minuten will sie sich
wieder voller Energie zeigen die
Zwillinge kommen von der Schule nach
Hause
hallo na
er war warmuen schlecht warum als erstes
stehen die Mathe Hausaufgaben an an
ihrem freien Tag kann die
Krankenschwester ihren Kindern dabei
helfen sonst übernimmt das Jessicas
Mutter die knapp 25 km entfernt wohnt
und fast jeden Tag
kommt sie betreut ihre Enkel nachmittags
und bringt sie oft abends ins Bett wenn
Jessica spät
50 Minuten Unterstützung vom Vater der
Kinder bekommt Jessica so gut wie gar
nicht nee das K er sieht seine Kinder
nur etwa dreimal im Jahr
20:5r die ersten zwei Jahre habe ich
gewütet und geschrien und geheult
wenn die Kinder nicht dabei waren
und habe ich alles versucht das
irgendwie
durchzuboxen weil ich dachte meine
Kinder haben Recht darauf ne die die
haben Recht darauf mit ihrem Vater
Kontakt Kontakt zu haben aber
es bringt nichts es bringt nichts du
kannst schreien und wüten und heulen wie
du willst es bringt nichts wenn der
andere nicht will und dann habe ich
damit aufgehört habe ich mir GT ist
völlig verschwendete
Energie Energie verschwenden das kann
sich Jessica nicht leisten jeder Funke
davon wird gebraucht um den Alltag zu
bewältigen jetzt noch mal 10
Minuten in Berlin gibt es bei Familie
Abendessen Vater Ingolf hat zusammen mit
Tochter Lisa gekocht es gibt Seelachs
mit Rotkraut und
Reis am Tisch dreht sich das Gespräch um
die Mutter eigentlich wollten sich Lisa
und Anna morgen mit ihr treffen aber sie
hat abgesagt Kön mal überlegen was wir
morgen
machen Spielplatz
nein wir treffen doch morgen Mama ne
morgen Mama
Mama als Mama kann man nicht ersetzen in
dem Sinne ne man kann halt
gucken dass man versucht die Rolle zu
übernehmen und ich habe auch gelernt
aufzupassen dass die große nicht die
Mutterrolle übernimmt für die
kleine Anna und Lisa sind im Bett Ingolf
hat sich an den Computer gesetzt aber
nicht zum Zeitvertreib er durchforstet
mal wieder das Internet nach
Stellenanzeigen der Garten und
landschaftsbauhelfer sucht dringend
einen neuen Job der jetztzige
Arbeitgeber der zahlt halt nicht immer
pünktlich und es ist ja schon eine
Belastung in dem Sinne dass man halt
sich jeden Tag Gedanken machen muss
kriegt man jetzt rechtzeitig das Geld
und wie sieht die die Perspektive in der
Zukunft aus ne deswegen gucke auch dass
ich halt ich sag mal ein Arbeitgeber
finde der also auch regelmäßig zahlt ne
und ver
30 Bewerbungen hat Ingolf schon
rausgeschickt bisher ohne
[Musik]
Erfolg 14 Uhr in Halle die Schule ist
aus Finja fahenbach holt ihre Mutter von
der Arbeit ab der gemeinsame nach
Hauseweg verspricht 30 Minuten exklusiv
Zeit mit Mama jetzt muss die 16jährige
alles loswerden was heute passiert ist
ich a gerechnet so Sport meine erste
Stunde absolut nichts gemacht wieso habt
ihr nichts gemacht ich denke ihr lauft
haben nichts geschaff ich weiß dass Mama
da immer nicht so viel zu sagen bekommt
weil ich immer so alles raus klappere
aber ich ich find's ich find's schön
dass wir so ein paar Minuten haben wo
ich so alles erzählen
kann ja Mama hat ja noch zwei andere
Kinder und
und es ist dann halt zwischendurch schon
ein bisschen stressig
aber ich finde es immer sehr entspannend
wenn wir so ein paar Minuten für uns
haben so Jen Fall kriegen wir noch mehr
Zeit Finja muss im Altag oft
zurückstecken ihr jüngster Bruder hat
eine sozial emotionale
Entwicklungsstörung und braucht
besonders viel Zeit und
Aufmerksamkeit ein Spagat für Mutter
Madlen die Balance gibt's nicht
ich kann auch nicht allen gerecht werden
das ist
unrealistisch das musste ich mir aber
auch erst selbst eingestehen also ich
wollte immer allen gerecht werden auch
mir selbst und das klappt einfach nicht
weil so viel Stunden hat der Tag
[Musik]
m nicht nur die Kinder fordern Madlen im
Alltag auch die Sorge um die finanzielle
Zukunft der Familie
belastet
seit fast vier Monaten hofft sie dass
ihr Folgeantrag fürs Wohngeld bewilligt
wird Geld dass sie dringend braucht
zumal der Vater der Kinder weniger
Unterhalt zahlt als er soll
375 € fehlen jeden Monat in der
Kasse Madlen beantragt deshalb jetzt für
die Kinder einen Rechtsbeistand der die
Zahlungen einfordern
kann was los muss das für jedes Kind
einzeln ausfüen
das heißt ich muss es auch noch zweimal
ausdrucken ich finde die Bürokratie
unglaublich anstrengend ich fühle mich
sehr alleinelassen und ich finde das so
dermaßen übergriffig was sich manche
erlauben da zu
teilen mir wurde schon gesagt na du
wolltest ja du wolltest das ja so du
wolltest die drei Kinder du wolltest du
du hast dich entschieden dich zu trennen
natürlich habe ich mich entschieden ja
und ich wollte auch die drei Kinder
vielleicht nicht so wie es jetzt ist und
natürlich habe ich mir das mal alles
irgendwie anders und schöner vorgestellt
ne ich habe mir nie gewünscht
alleinerziehen zu sein die ständige
Belastung wirkt sich auf Körper und
Seele von Alleinerziehenden aus ihnen
geht es gesundheitlich oft schlechter
als Eltern in
Paarfamilien was haben wir jetzt 2013
egal ob es um Migräne geht um
Übergewicht Zahngesundheit
Rückenschmerzen oder um
Depressionen jeder sagt halt ja dann
mach doch mal was für dich mach doch
sport mach doch
das
wann ich bin manch abends einfach nur
noch erschöpft ich habe einfach
zwischendurch gar keine gar keinen gar
kein ich ich kann einfach nicht mehr
ne aber madelen hat keine Wahl sie muss
weitermachen
täglich über die Belastungsgrenze gehen
das macht auch Ingolf Kersten als
alleinerziehender Vater wird er häufig
nicht ernst genommen viele Anlaufstellen
fühlen sich nicht für ihn
zuständig aber hier bekommt er Hilfe die
Anlaufstelle für Alleinerziehende in
trepto köik hi schön dich zu sehen
endlich in
3dgolf sucht Rat bei der
Sozialarbeiterin dan erte se Tochter
Anna eine sogenannte Einzelfallhilfe
beim Jugendamt beantragen eine Person
die sich regelmäßig mit Anna trifft und
sie bei ihrer Persönlichkeitsentwicklung
unterstützt also dass jemand Zeit mit
Anna verbringt und sie sich da nicht mal
für gewisse Stunden vielleicht mal mit
sich alleine beschäftigen muss wenn ich
mal keine Ahnung Termine habe oder was
auch immer also ist sie so selbstbewusst
kann sie traut sie sich was zu sagen
wenn sie tatsächlich ein Anliegen hat
komm kommt schon vor aber es sie ist da
sehr zurücktilend da muss sie da muss
sie stabilisiert werden genau das wäre
z.B weniger die Entlastung für dich ja
sondern eher so okay eine einzelverhilfe
für Anna in wieern könnte Anna von
profitieren und Selbstwert ist dann
wahrscheinlich ein gutes Thema was du
nach vorne bringen könntest ann
Selbstwert stärken mit diesem Argument
hat ingrolfs Antrag beim Jugendamt
Chancen auf Erfolg glaubt
mos die Sozialarbeiterin macht ihren Job
schon seit 15 Jahren sie merkt wie
schwer es vielen fällt um Unterstützung
zu
bitten das wäre so meine Idee für viele
ist schon das Gespräch bei ihr eine
Hilfe vielleicht auch mit der
Betrachtung es kommen auch Männer zu mir
aber es sind eher Frauen die erstens
alleinerziehend sind und die auch die
große kehrarbeit haben die große Sorge
die Kinder leben immer noch zum größeren
Teil bei den Müttern
so nehmen sie einfach auch mehr Beratung
in Anspruch ich ich würde sagen wenn
Männer den Weg zu mir finden haben sie
eher pragmatischere
Fragen und suchen nach schnelleren
Lösungen hingegen
Frauen auch sehr viel sozial emotionale
Themen mitbringen auch schon mal das
Thema der
Gesundheit auch Ingolf spürt wie die
letzten drei Jahre als Alleinerziehender
an seiner Kraft gezehrt haben er will
sich mehr um seine Gesundheit kümmern
auch um besser für die Kinder da sein zu
können mir fehlt ja Ruhe Zeit für mich
selber eine Auszeit ja die nehme ich mir
aber auch weil ich auch schon beantragt
habe eine vaterkindkur die steht
aberdings erst im April nächsten Jahres
an also ich habe fast ein Jahr auf eine
vaterkindkur mit Widerspruchsverfahren
also ich kenne mich schon mit
Widersprüchen
aus ja und mit den Kindern natürlich
zusammen dass man halt da auch ein
bisschen lernt für sich Zeit zu nehmen
und auch für was für sich für sein
Körper zu tun ingol fühlt sich auf einem
guten Weg er hat gelernt Hilfe
anzunehmen und ein neuer Job steht auch
in
Aussicht das Beste aus der Situation
machen das versucht auch Madlen in Halle
heute wird
geschockt auf dieser Kleidertauschparty
muss Madlen sich ausnahmsweise keine
Sorgen um die Kosten machen die Kinder
haben ihre alten Sachen aussortiert und
können Sie hier gegen andere Klamotten
eintaus
[Musik]
kostenlos Finja sucht eine neue Jacke
und norik ist schon wieder aus seinen
T-Shirts herausgewachsen eine gute
Gelegenheit um sich neu einzukleiden und
eine willkommene Abwechslung für Madlen
und ihre Familie jetzt ist frei ich
merke ja wie viel Stress Mama zwischen
euch hat und so und ich glaub das ist so
das was ich mir am meisten mit Wünsche
das einfach ist alles so einfacher wird
aber wie das gehen soll das weiß auch
fin ja
nicht die finanziellen Sorgen hängen
immer wie eine dunkle Wolke über der
Familie ich hätte gern echt Lust einmal
so in Urlaub zu machen so eine ich sag
jetzt mal so eine Woche wo ich nicht
drüber nachdenken muss wie könen wir uns
das leisten wie machen wir das und dann
halt auch aber ein Urlaub auch mit für
mich
ag ich Brau mir keine Gedanken Frühstück
machen oder so das wä schon so echt das
schönes
J ihr letzter gemeinsamer Urlaub eine
Woche in Greifswald ist schon eine Weile
her dafür hatte madelen zuvor 5 Jahre
lang
gespart in wird heute so viel erledigt
wie
möglichess n ihren eini in der Woche um
mit den Kindern zum Zahnarzt zu gehen
ist eine super Regelung so dann dürft
ihr euch hinsetzen Jungs ich stell mal
meine Tasche so lange hin so einmal an
den dreizug Kontrolle ja richtig die
Stunden und Minuten eines Tages bei
Jessica sind sie komplett
durchgetaktet es gab doch in der Werbung
früher mal dass irgendjemand gesagt hat
ich manage erfolgreich ein kleines
Familienunternehmen oder irgendwie sowas
da ich g sind beklubter Spruch aber es
ist genauso ich glaube es ist nichts
anderes als eine Firma zu organisieren
oder Mitarbeiter nur dass die Termine
eben Fußballtraining Sumba
Zahnarzt und sowas alles sind
Untersuchung ist im Prinzip genau das
gleiche
nur das halt nicht bezahlt wir es dafür
du darfst mal einmal den Spiegel in die
Hand nehmen bei Romi ist alles in
Ordnung bei Bennet sieht es nicht so gut
aus eine Entzündung ist im anm
Entzündung hast irgendwann geht die auf
den Knochen über und dann hast du schon
ganz FR und Henry hat eine Stelle mit
Kias das heißt Jessica muss mit ihm noch
einmal
wiederkom ja dann ma ich da würde ich
aber ich habe jetzt keinen Kalender
dabei da würde ich morgen noch mal
anrufen weil ich das ja dann auf den
freien Tag von mir legen muss damit ich
dann mit ihn damit das kommen kann okay
dann rufe ich morgen
an danke so auf geht's links links links
links Henry hier geht's lang
ein langer Tag geht für die Familie zu
Ende und schon war die kleine Fledermaus
tief und fest
eingeschlummert so wie ihr bestimmt auch
jetzt
so gute
Nacht gute Nacht soll ich die
schlafkatze
anmachen morgen früh um 5 Uhr klingelt
wieder der
Wecker immer funktionieren alles auf die
Reihe kriegen
müssen manchmal gibt es Tage an denen
Jessica sich nach Unterstützung durch
einen Partner
sehend wo soll er herkommen also ich
meine jetzt geht ja nicht gleich der
Fußboden auf und 15 Bewerber äh kommen
hier zum Vorschein ich bin ja nur hier
oder auf der Arbeit ich bin ja sonst
irgendwas ist relativ schwierig Kontakte
zu knüpfen und äh ja es wäre in vielen
Dingen schon schön ein paar zu haben
allein um sich mal über manche Dinge
austauschen zu können das fehlt mir
tatsächlich fast am meisten Fragen auch
viele warum hast du noch keinen
kennengelernt jetzt seit 5 Jahren so und
ja ist halt auch schwierig ne wenn es
soweit ist wird schon jemand kommen
denke
ich bis dahin muss sie aber weiter Job
Alltag und Kindererziehung alleine
bewältigen so wie Millionen andere
Alleinerziehende in
Deutschland FE
H